we're back i'm here with charles gardens
now i i've i'd like to ask you this
right now you've been doing this for a
long time you know you were going on
these shows with carson you go on the
shows with letterman
started i think in 1973 with johnny
carson that was your first uh talk show
appearance i was on
i was on the show ran till one o'clock
at night at that time it was an hour and
a half
and i was on it seven minutes to one and
then they
asked me to come back three weeks later
and i was on it ten minutes to one
and the next day the guy who the talent
coordinator for the show
i was at the they put you up at the
beverly hills hotel he called and he
said
johnny carson wants to put you under
contract as a as a talk show guest
well did you ever hear of anything like
that we don't have the money to do stuff
like that no we can't pull that off no i
wasn't suggesting that i come under
contract to you
that's not the that's completely not now
that you bring it up
i was just getting into that part of the
appearance where i give you my credits
and resumes
i thought that's what we were doing i'm
sorry oh no i thought that's what you
asked
no this is so embarrassing my next story
was about when i won this award
i've totally misunderstood what a great
honor was i'm sorry it's my fault
i'm sorry i'm leading somewhere with
this my question to you is
my question is you have a very dry sense
of fuel do people always get you
no no i mean does anybody know what i'm
talking about do you know what anything
that i'm talking about today
absolutely look at that there's like
one guy really thank you
you get it right tell your failure tell
your partners
uh i'm on cable you know that's why
you're on cable
what are you doing no you're on cable
because you don't try to appeal to
a a you know millions and millions of
people across the country
right you appeal to people that
basically uh
you know like a dry sense of humor type
of thing i see
don't just slavishly try and impress
anyone with any kind of boobish comedy
bit
exactly right i mean i was i was going
to develop a show like this and i
one of the things i was gonna i was
gonna uh have a horse that could type
you know that's the kind of stuff we
were doing
wait a minute well that's not to say i
couldn't have a horse that could type on
my show
that's not a bad bit i could do out of
cable you could have a horse that could
type on it
yeah people would love that that's what
i might do i'm glad that came out of
this
more good ideas come out of these
sessions and then i won the uh the
clarence derwin
oh i miss i'm sorry what did you say
no let's hear about the awards well
you've had a long successful career
you've conquered movies you've conquered
movies movies television radio
books i've written books so sorry you've
written books you know what i used to do
i used to uh be the director and writer
for candid camera how many of you have
heard of candice cameron how many people
you've worn many hats you did you you
worked some uh very strange jobs but
before you began acting is that true
this is one of them
this is a strange job you come out here
to all how many people are sitting there
300 people sitting we have over 800
people in our studio audience
isn't that true 800 sometimes 900 or a
thousand people
i mean there are nights charles i'm
sorry it's not uncommon for us to have
15
1800 people in the studio audience well
you know i mean it's
forget about me here because you you're
here all the time you come out in front
of 8 900 people
and and what's up what's the first thing
you said tonight when you came out what
was that first joke i said please sit
down a standing ovation is not
no where was there someone you had what
was your first it's hard to remember but
what was the first joke you had when you
came i don't remember
it was about i did it's not the one i
gave you which one was it i don't know
if you remember
clinton 78 of people and the other
wanted to shoot him so you say you say
that and seven seventy-eight percent of
people like him and the other twenty-two
percent
shot at the white house and and you hope
that these eight hundred people find
that amusing or sometimes
fifteen hundred well if you
the more you increase the numbers the
more chance you have at somebody as long
as you just get like eight people just
to go
ah yeah right okay you know as long as
you hear some sound
that'll keep you on the air this late at
night you don't have to do that much
andy and i just slap
on some fake ties come out here and
jabber like monkeys and it seems to work
well the the sleep function is our worst
enemy
the one that turns the tv off while you
sleep oh do they
yeah do they have those they do have it
now that's the biggest threat to the
issue of your rating son
they will the minute that thing gets
implemented in a lot of nielsen homes
that's dangerous
i think it no i think it's a great show
for people you know
who are asleep you know baby yeah
and i went that's what i'm doing here
basically we're out here
trying not to wake anybody up
just keep it very quiet very quiet
and i think in that context you're like
the biggest thing that ever hit
television
thank you
okay i think we just i think we just
woke a lot of people yeah
yeah i know that was great that was
really it was a lot of that was a lot of
fun
it was a lot of fun we did we learned
you're a lot of fun
yeah yeah
you know what happens a lot yeah the
united states of america is a great
country yes
it's a great and and oh
they like tv they don't like you america
you were riding high
yeah i know i mentioned yeah mentioned
the background for america i just want
to say that
okay i'm ready i mean i'm ready to go
can i go you can go
now let me plug this show you what i'm
sorry
yeah you got your ten o'clock show and
talk back america three monday april
17th that's a special
that's a special with geraldo rivera and
phil donahue and me and seven other
people that you would have heard off
whose names you know
i don't know mention everybody's names
man you plug the hell out of that
you know it's great all right well
listen it was really nice having you
here thank you
great pleasure thank you everybody